et oui gilles verdez excusez moi mais
vous ça fait un petit moment que je vous
regarde
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous connaissez ce
monsieur valérie benaïm vous pouvez
venir une minute qu'est-ce qui s'occupe
qu'est-ce qui s'occupe de cyril hanouna
normalement c'est vous mokhtar qu'est ce
qui se passe ce monsieur n'est pas cyril
hanouna
ce monsieur n'est pas cyril hanouna
c'est le toucher le toucher le nom mais
c'est lui il lui ressemble et celui
montas il est où cyril hanouna ce
monsieur est un artiste transformiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même pas
regardez c'est la même barbare regardez
c'est la même barbe touche est touché
c'est là mais cyril hanouna il est beau
le monsieur il est pas beau